good evening community candles and
plenty of hugs at the ceremony for
trooper micah may thanks for joining us
at 11 i'm denise valdez
may was killed last week while trying to
stop a suspect in a car chase
madison kimbrough is live from police
memorial park where a vigil was held
tonight
madison we're hearing that it was a
really special night and there was a
very large turnout too
according to his fellow officers
tonight's turnout was inspiring
as the las vegas community came together
to honor the fallen hero
micah loved his job and he loved being a
street trooper
he found great joy in taking bad people
off the road
tonight a candlelight vigil held for
nevada highway patrol trooper
micah may
[Music]
may lost his life thursday at umc after
being hit by a carjacking suspect
that he was attempting to stop on i-15
last week
local law enforcement friends and family
all gathered at police memorial park
to remember the 46-year-old husband and
father of two
i know that he gave his life doing what
he loved he came to work every day and
he did his job
but yet when the chips were down he was
the first guy responding and the first
person on scene
towards the end of the ceremony candles
were lit in a moment of silence
on sunday law enforcement escorted
trooper may's body from the coroner's
office to palm mortuary in downtown las
vegas
and may's wife joanna announced this
evening that may's organs were donated
saving four people's lives in the
process micah saved so many lives as a
graveyard guardian he kept this valley
safe
joanna you and the kids will never walk
alone
that i promise you
and a service will be held this friday
at 11 a.m at central christian church
there will also be a procession that
starts at 9
30 a.m reporting live madison kimbrough
8 news now